foreign
[Music]
good morning and welcome to today's
webinar titled variant interpretation
literature curation and clinical trials
oh my how to simplify somatic NGS
analysis and reduce literature review
Time by 90 with hsmd my name is Caitlin
and I will be the host and moderator for
today's session presented by labroots
and brought to you by kyogen digital
insights or QDI the bioinformatics
business of kyogen and the leading
provider of genomic and clinical
knowledge as well as analysis and
interpretation tools and services for
scientists and clinicians for more
information please visit
www.digitalinsights.cogen.com
we'd like to extend a special welcome to
the nsgc members who've joined us today
thanks for filling our virtual seats and
we really hope to make this presentation
particularly relevant for all of you
today
over the next hour our speakers Chelsea
Alexander project manager for the
Professional Services Group at QDI and
former certified genetic counselor and
RT govern lead scientist for oncology
application development at QDI we'll
discuss current trends in somatic
testing and the corresponding challenges
faced by modern genetic counselors and
clinical cancer professionals focusing
on a new tool designed to streamline
simplify and shorten the life cycle of
somatic NGS testing in light of these
challenges we encourage you to
participate today by submitting any
questions that you might have during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
Send we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation and any questions that we
don't get to we'll follow up with via
email the email that you provided at
registration
if needed you may also submit any
technical issues in the ask a question
box as well such as if you have any
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
one more thing before we begin our legal
disclaimer kaijin products shown here
are intended for molecular biology
applications and not intended for the
diagnosis treatment or prevention of a
disease for up-to-date licensing
information or product specific
disclaimers please see our website
www.caijin.com
and with that let's get started Chelsea
why don't you begin by talking a bit
about your experience as a genetic
counselor maybe give us a breakdown of
your day-to-day how you spent your time
um and the challenges that you faced
uh thanks Caitlin so much
um like anything you know genetic
counseling as a practice has continued
to evolve and adapt to changing needs
and influences technology as well as new
knowledge
um as many genetic counselors there can
relate to a lot of the the activities
that we do kind of on a day-to-day or
directly outside of a patient-facing
visit
um looking back at uh you know I was a
clinical giant counselor for eight years
and I've noticed that I think that there
were phases where the time spent that I
spent on specific activities and patient
care related activities was particularly
Salient and
um I'm gonna break those down into the
three areas specifically so one of the
first transitions where the access to
appropriate resources I think was
critically helpful was the difference
between grad school and moving to
clinical genetic counseling practice the
amount of time spent on non-patient
relating activities in
transitioning to my first role was I
found a little bit surprising
um as that's not something that
necessarily all genetic counseling
programs really delve into
um and so that initial transition into
clinical genetic counseling work
including EMR documentation or
electronic medical record documentation
Insurance authorization information
surrounding billing and coding as well
as care coordination both with my um you
know the other individuals in the
multi-disciplinary clinic that we worked
with as well as social workers or other
things like that or care providers I saw
as a really big transition
so and that is in addition to the kind
of patient related activities as such as
researching results literature review as
well as the time and effort going into
patient care
um so getting up to speed with all of
the non-schools related aspects and
being a healthcare provider I felt uh
kind of maybe a little underprepared as
far as the resources available to me the
second time is transitioning to a new
clinical specialty so I have moved into
different Specialties throughout my
clinical practice and this as many of my
juicy colleagues can probably attest to
comes with a new set of challenges so
getting up to date on the knowledge the
expertise the background information
either starting a new clinical genetic
counseling practice or establishing
relationships within care providers all
takes a lot of effort
um and those new processes getting up to
Patient Care and also um knowing what
resources are available in those spaces
um it comes with new challenges and
searching for resources and genetic
testing that's appropriate as well as
understanding processes
as well and then the last part that I
think is
particularly relevant especially for
current current day and age is when
there's a technology shift
so I've you know technology and
navigating the new transition when new
testing or results or genes are added or
new panels specifically with the items
tasks like literature review can be
really daunting to Patient Care I think
um and so I
versioning technology right now moving
into the kind of somatic space I think I
see that as a technology shift in
something where additional resources can
be really helpful
to further this point you know some of
the historical shifts project counseling
and success have been written by some of
our colleagues I'll Point into an
article by Bob resta
um from 2019 as far as a history of
measuring the success of genetic
counseling which I found particularly
interesting
um but he specifically talks about new
testing Technologies and how this kind
of created a flurry of activity in the
jail accounting world for example when
amniocentesis came out my internal serum
screening uh you know we've seen
different challenges there are different
transitions as well between now whole
exome
non-vasive prenatal testing as well as
whole genome as well and so the the
influences of these testing this changes
technology changes have influenced
practice and what this looks like so I
think
clinical giant counselors who have been
practicing for a little longer the
transition even from what channel
counting looked like and the resources
available and what our day-to-day looks
like even from the early 2000s has
shifted dramatically
um and we've been having to practice and
adapting to these new technologies the
new kind of scope of practice and what
we're supposed to do in these
Transitions and a lot of us do remember
the transition for micro rate and NGS to
whole genome and exome and now recently
that has kind of spanned into the
semantic NGS space as well with semantic
testing and so with this notable shift
in tumor testing and genetic counselors
involvement in somatic variant
interpretation and transition to Patient
Care
this is where hsmd could come come into
play
yeah definitely
um first of all thank you Chelsea um
it's really interesting to learn more
about the rich history of the genetic
counseling profession and the challenges
faced by GCS uh I've been working in the
Precision oncology space for several
years
um and to some extent I have witnessed
the evolution
of the space when it comes to how tumor
genomic profiling is more broadly
adopted
um now compared to
um several years ago more institutions
are performing tumor genomic profiling
um using commercial panels or you know
customizing and creating their own NGS
panels and even commercial NGS panels
are getting larger with more and more
genes um being interrogated more
variants to detect so I think you know
we live in a really exciting age
um with these new technologies
um supporting more treatment options for
cancer patients
um coming back to your experience as a
GC
um you know I've had the privilege of
collaborating with some amazing GCS like
you uh who are working on variant
interpretation they're really passionate
about helping patients and um I did want
to know like more about how much time do
GCS spend typically on one patient
um you know when it comes to research
and reviewing literature reviewing
testing results for a patient and so on
and so forth like I If you could
ballpark that
um I'd like to know more
thank you arthy I appreciate the
question
um
there has been particular efforts uh to
outline genetic counseling workflow and
time studies and I am going to reference
one of the recent ones in a paper by
Courtney addard uh at all in 2019 in the
journal engine counseling they looked at
genetic counseling work more
specifically
um and I'm sure a lot of other
individuals have the same experience
where personally I've worked at
institutions where we've had to do time
studies to
um Garner support for additional
internet counselors or FTE or things
like that to kind of note what we were
spending our time on so particularly in
those in previous studies you know a
three hours of patient limited
activities were performed
um and less than that you know less than
one hour was was spent in face to face
time with patients
um it is often this kind of unseen work
that I think can be really challenging
from a j counseling just because it's
it's not seen kind of to other providers
or our patients even as far as the
amount of work that goes in both
prepping for a patient visit as well as
kind of coordinating what needs to be
happened after so
in particular
there have been time studies
president Counseling Services even back
through the 80s and 90s and early 2000s
as well
um so
they have shown that often there's about
seven hours per new patient and 3.5
hours for returning patients spend on
these non um patient-facing related
activities
and that was a study by Bernard at all
into in 1987.
um I think specifically some of the kind
of hidden work or so these this
additional challenges
um that FaceTime counselors is
navigating all of the kind of Downstream
impact that happens after seeing a
patient
um and I think there are there's other
evidence to support that specifically in
the somatic realm
um and the burgeoning systematic tumor
testing as well that it is taking a lot
of time and effort for genetic
counselors to do
um for example the nsgc has the
development of a cancer special interest
group pilot for on-demand cases review
Services through the nsgc which I think
is an amazing service a lot of
Institutions or places of practice might
have their own tumor boards for patient
case review and things like that and so
you're putting a lot of really smart
people together to think about the best
way to treat a patient and what makes
the most sense and all of that takes
time and effort
and so it's clear that individuals who
are preventing genetic counseling
especially um in this context need as
much information as possible and that
resources are being actively developed
to support them
um and so hsmd could possibly help with
that yeah definitely Chelsea uh what
hsmd does best is provide expert curated
information for somatic cancer variants
um hence the name human somatic mutation
database hsmd contains more than 300 000
clinically observed ovariance in cancer
that were manually interpreted by our
team of precision oncology scientists
and in addition it contains several
hundred thousand more variants that were
manually curated from the literature and
also contains drug approvals oncology
practice guidelines and clinical trials
I'll point you to a case study uh Dr
Anna kravacica and her colleagues at The
Institute for oncology and Radiology of
Serbia
um they were one of the early adopters
of hsmd and they reported to us that
they were able to substantially reduce
the time that they spent on variant
curation
um and that's actually where the up to
90 reduction in literature review time
in the webinar title comes from so um I
encourage you to check out the case
study which I believe is linked in the
resources section if you want to learn
more
um
I'll sum it up by saying um I think for
lab GCS hsmd can be really a very useful
tool
um it can help reduce curation time uh
significantly and similarly for clinical
genetics professionals and clinical GCS
hsmd also has a lot of valuable
resources so um I think it has something
for each one of you whether you are
working in the lab or working more on
the clinical side
um so now I think is the perfect time
for us to dive straight in to hsmd and
um see a demo
um so that I can show you all the cool
features
um so yep hold on let me share my screen
okay
welcome to human somatic mutation
database cool this is the hsmd landing
page and as you can see there's a search
bar here where you can search by Gene
alteration
protein change or coding change or even
structural variants and um
by drug disease or clinical trial
and down here the numbers basically tell
you how many genes alterations diseases
drugs and trials are represented in hsmd
as of this particular moment
um if you go to an explore page
you'll get high level information about
for example if you go to the explore
genes page it will tell you which genes
are covered by hsmd and provide high
level information about the number of
variants that are curated for a
particular Gene and the number of
associated drugs and clinical trials and
so on so let's start by looking at the
explore genes page
all right so this is the gene Explorer
as you can see hsmd contains
a large number of genes more than 1400
and on this page we've provided some
high level information for each gene um
that is covered by hsmd to enable you to
search sort and filter according to the
information that's provided here for
example
the genes are classified as oncogenes or
tumor suppressors and if there's
insufficient evidence to classify them
as one or the other then they are listed
as not established and similarly you can
search for genes that have at least one
variant that falls into a specific
category like um let's say with a
functional impact of known and
activating
and you can search for genes that are
that have at least one variant that is
tier one
so
for this example let's look at oncogenes
all right so uh by default it's sorted
by the number of variants per Gene
highest to lowest and so egfr is the one
that has the highest number of variants
curated and yeah there will be instances
where genes are listed as both oncogene
and tumor suppressor because they maybe
one or the other uh depending on the
context
and
as you can see there are a lot of the a
lot of these are
well-known oncogenes and for the sake of
showing you an example I am going to
pick pick 3ca whenever you see that
an entry is underlined and in blue it
means that it's hyperlinked to another
page so for example clicking on pick3ca
here will take you to the gene page for
pick3ca
all right so this is the victory CA Gene
page every Gene page starts off with a
description summarizing the role of a
gene in cancer and its function
you also have external links to take you
to other databases or resources if you
want to check them out as well for a
particular Gene and then you have these
two sections alteration type and
functional impact and actionability
distribution will provide a breakdown of
the number of alterations in this Gene
that are
represented in hsmd and basically
categorizing them according to
alteration type the functional impact
type and actionability classification
so here let me take a moment to tell you
how we assess actionability uh the
actionability classification in hsmd is
based on the 2017 and Pasco cap
guidelines and
the actionability that you will see for
ovariant is the highest actionability
across all cancer types so we are well
aware that Labs will sometimes have
their own protocols and their own
classification systems
hsmd aims to provide the evidence that
you need to arrive at a particular
classification for a variant but the
actionability that we provide is just a
guide based on the amp guidelines
and I think the coolest
graphs on this page are observed
clinical case distribution and
alteration distribution
The observed clinical case distribution
graph presents data that was extracted
from our real world clinical oncology
data set so um remember I told you that
our team of scientists
have manually interpreted more than 300
000 clinically absorbed variants so
these variants were observed in clinical
cases that were sent for interpretation
to our professional interpretation
service team
and represents a large number of
real-world cancer patient samples so
what this graph shows is the mutational
frequency
of the gene in different cancer types as
observed in our clinical data set so as
you can see in the table lovular breast
adenocarcinoma is the cancer type which
demonstrated the highest mutational
frequency for pig3ca and if you hover
over the bar for lobular
breastedynocarcinoma in the graph that's
shown next to it you see that it it
shows you a functional impact breakdown
so for all the variants in pictures that
have been observed in lobby
libertadinocarcinoma it shows you how
those variants were classified so in
this case 48 of them were actually
assessed to be known activating
mutations in pick 3ci
and you can get similar information for
other cancer types as well in from the
graph
the alteration distribution graph below
it is also presenting data from our
clinical data set and what this is
showing you is a it's a lollipop graph
presenting the frequency with Rich
mutations at a particular codon of
pict3ca have been observed in clinical
cases so
as you can see here there are quite a
few hot spot hot spots within pics 3ca
where mutations are more frequent and
h1047 stands out there's an e726 of
course e545 e542
um and so on and 345 okay so as an
example let's click on this
okay so when you click on a lollipop
corresponding to a particular codon it
navigates you to the alterations table
and basically filters the table to show
only those mutations that occur at the
specific codon
here you see there are a whole lot of
different amino acid changes at n345
that are that have been clinically
absorbed are part of our data set
and
okay let's look let's clear this search
and look at all variants in um pick 3ca
tier four tier one okay so so
you can see that for the 6000
alterations in pick3ca that are on hsmd
they're the chromosome position the
genomic coordinates coding change
protein change and other information
available for each one of them
I think the cool thing about the
alterations table on the gene page is
that you can also search for alterations
in a specific genomic range so for
example what shall we look at okay for
example let's look at
this 88
to
118.
search
and then you can sort by position to see
them in order yeah there you go so now
it has filtered the list down further to
show you only the mutations that occur
within the range that you've entered in
here
and that way even if you're looking for
a particular alteration and it doesn't
happen to be in hsmd you can look to see
if there are any alterations that
neighboring residues that have been
reported before so I think that's really
cool and
oh yeah one more thing I wanted to point
out here is that you'll notice there are
two different Source types we've already
talked about clinically observed it's a
part of our clinical oncology data set
KB means that even though this variant
has not been reported in a clinical case
as part of our data set it has however
been reported in the literature and our
curators have essentially curated
information from the literature for this
variant in some cases you may have
functional studies information available
in other cases you may have some
clinical case information available for
those particular mutations but kaijin KB
basically indicates that there is at
least one reference that mentions this
particular mutation in the literature
so I think one thing that I just want to
call out in in addition to the genetic
testing results which gen counselors are
going over either in a lab setting or a
clinical setting as well
um specifically to clinical setting the
other relevant data that can be really
pertinent and critical to Patient Care
is often difficult and to find or
navigate resources that are currently
available and so one of those areas can
be FDA driver approvals so for
colleagues who work either in medical
Affairs in other institutions or
individuals who are working in the
clinical practice tracking down
information about new drug approvals
specifically for new indications or
existing drugs that are being remarketed
and targeted to a specific variant or
mutation that can be really challenging
for what I have seen and what can I what
I have experienced having information
within hsmd that is very specific with
that kind of information available seems
like it could be really helpful
yeah so right so the
the two sections that I did not get to
are drugs and clinical trials so
okay let me zoom in a little bit
so for example right
I'm interested in Pick 3 CA mutations
and I see
in the drug section
I
can actually look for drugs that we know
are associated with a sensitive response
when a pick 3ca mutation or activating
mutation is present and so for example
here El pelisib is FDA approved
and well it's FDA and email approved but
specifically it is FDA approved for
treatment of pick 3ca mutation positive
breast cancer so what you see here under
specificity is the specific mutations
that in pick 3ca that are detected
by the companion diagnostic for El
pelisib and
so those mutations are listed here as
conferring sensitivity to El pelicid
full of Strand and as part of the FDA
approval
Additionally you can
also see like let's say we're talking
about a gene that actually doesn't have
any specific indications any FDA
approvals for that specific biomarker
positive cancer I think that's where
specificity of targeted
comes in handy where we know that the
drug in this case does Target pick 3ca
it's one of the targets of el Palace
similarly carbon license is FDA approved
in lymphoma by not specifically in the
context of big3ca mutation positive
cancer but it does Target Pick 3 CA and
develop also does Target Pick 3 CA so I
think the drug section
provides a lot of that additional
information also you know if you click
on this link it'll take you to the drug
page for alpala said follow the Strand
and
essentially what the drug page shows you
is the at the top of the page you have a
summary of the FDA and email indications
for the drug and then below you'll have
a list of the biomarkers that are known
to be associated with sensitivity or
resistance to that particular drug
so I think that's that's really
that could be really useful and what
else I don't so pick 3ca not a great
example for resistance but let's look at
an ALK mutation shall we
um okay I'm gonna use this search here
and pull up and
all commutation
okay all F 1174l this is the alteration
page for this mutation and as you can
see similar to the gene page we have a
description that our scientists have put
together for this particular mutation
after reviewing all the evidence that's
available for for it in the literature
in professional guidelines drug
approvals and so on
and the description for uh all f1174l
you know specifies that it is known to
be activating and have transforming
activity from functional studies and in
addition it calls out resistance to
therapies like crazy
I I think it's it can really be useful
also to have this sort this level of
detail where um the mutation is shown as
being detected in a patient with a
particular tumor type who developed
resistance to Croissant nib and it also
includes details about pre-clinical
evidence for sensitivity or resistance
to particular drugs so I think that
that's that could be something that's
really helpful as well
and similarly the alteration page has
this drugs table you can just kind of
yep you can pick resistance as the
response if you want to look
particularly at drugs associated with a
response of resistance for tumors
harboring this mutation and yeah this is
you know in a nutshell this is the sort
of information you can get for drugs and
then you know there is information for
clinical trials as well
that's great because in searching and
finding for what is pertinent to your
specific patient as far as like open and
recruiting clinical trials eligibility
on clinicaltrials.gov and other
resources I have found that incredibly
challenging personally and so having
this information in a kind of collated
format that is has some link up to
relevant information seems like it could
be really really helpful and useful to
patients yeah and
you see here in the clinical trials
table it lists the drugs that are being
investigated for patients with analog
mutation the disease type phase and
again here if you click on this it's
hyperlinked to a trial page for this
specific trial and you know there are
actually multiple ways to search for
trials in hsmd you can search through
the clinical trial Section on the
alteration page and on like the gene
page but another way to do it is to use
the clinical trial Explorer and I'll
tell you why I like this option
because here not only can you enter in a
specific you know child
let's say recruiting patients for
mutations in a specific Gene you can
enter in the alteration as well
um or search by by specific drug but one
thing that I I really love about the
trial Explorer is that it allows you to
search for trials by country by location
and radius
okay let's try out one example I'm
looking for a trial for a patient with
an arid 1A mutation
So I entered that into the gene I'm
going to say USA
United States
search by location okay let's try
Chicago
there we go Chicago Illinois you can
pick distance I'm gonna say 50 miles
search
up look at that so we have we've pulled
up three trials
that are close to Chicago and recruiting
patients with an arid1a mutation and so
now I'm gonna okay let me click on this
to show you what what the trial page
looks like yeah so there's a description
there's a link out to the
clinicaltrials.gov page for this trial
there's some trial details and location
look Chicago Illinois
and you can look
scrolling below
it's recruiting patients
with arid1a mutation positive ovarian
carcinoma endometrial urothelial and
broader solid tumors in general so
yeah this is what you can do with the
clinical trial Explorer in hsmd
so um this next segment is for those of
you who aren't completely focused on
thematic variant interpretation with the
expansion of somatic NGS testing most of
the commercial labs are doing tumor only
testing
um and there was an entire session at
the association for molecular
pathology's annual meeting last year
devoted to discussing
um the benefits of Performing
um tumor normal paired sequencing not
simply just to subtract out germline
variants but also to perform a focused
analysis of genes or known to be
associated with hereditary cancer
predisposing syndromes so um we know
that because
um most labs are performing tumor only
testing a lot of times you may pick up
presumed germline pathogenic variants
in the somatic NGS test so as gc's
how are you handling this and um would
you say that
um there's a shift in the involvement of
GCS uh throughout the tumor testing
process be it somatic be it germline
um just having someone speak to the
patient making it clear to them that
even with tumor testing they may
potentially be notified of some sort of
um you know some germline finding that
could have implications not only uh for
their own treatment but also for their
family
um so can you tell me more about how
that the GC field is evolving um in that
area
yeah thanks arthy
um so alternate counselors
in grad school and Beyond learned about
the possibility of the possibility of
somatic or germline mosaicism and this
can be relevant to any specialty or
subspecialty but related to India
specifically with somatic testing and
best practices they are actively being
defined for example the nsgc has a Lynch
syndrome practice resource resource that
was developed in January of 2022 and the
authors I think particularly were very
thoughtful about including information
to consider to assist with this
navigating these new processes and the
possibility of these results
the complex results based for nsgc based
tumor profiling as it's becoming more
and more common so some of the things
that they pointed out are you know some
variants identified on tumor General
genomic profiling they actually may
represent germline variants with
clinical significant implications so
like you said having information up
front and internet counselors involved
prior to genetic testing in this medic
case I think is incredibly important to
be able to have that discussion with the
patient
um because it does have implications for
their health as well as their family
additionally
uh confirmatory genetic testing is then
recommended for individuals who have
tumor genomic profiling results that
identify a pathogenic variant or likely
pathogenic variant that is suspected by
germline and we know that that
information might not be uh the same
coming from all Labs you might have
different test results and different
variant information and so I think
genetic counselors and providers need to
think in the back of their head and have
and be aware that not all commercial
commercial tumor profiling tests or
platforms are created equal and I think
yeah that's right um that's a great
point because
um I'm not sure that all all Labs call
out the possibility that a variant could
Beach online so
um you know it's really important to
keep in mind that you might as you know
you could assume it's a somatic variant
because the lab hasn't called it out on
their report but um it could very well
be germline I think that's part of the
challenge when it comes to
differentiating between somatic and
Drumline variants
um you know there was a time when um
variant allele frequencies that fall
within the 40 to 60 range was
um used to differentiate the germline
variants from somatic but we know that
that's not a perfect indicator either
um so yeah I think um there are still
there's still quite a bit work to be
done in terms of solidifying the best
practices when it comes to
um reporting out variants from a test
and being really transparent about the
results and about what can and cannot be
detected by a particular test you know
like somatic versus germline and also uh
what can and cannot be reported by a
particular lab depending on no I totally
agree I I think I totally agree
um as genetic counselors I think we're
pretty well versed in making sure we
pick the right test at the right lab for
the right patient but making sure that
we know that not all tests are created
equal not all Labs might have the option
for germline testing and one thing that
I thought was really powerful about hsmd
when I was learning about it is that the
information is lab agnostic is that
right
yes that's right our professional
interpretation Service uh Team receives
uh cases from Labs all over the country
and as we've just talked about most
commercial labs are performing tumor
only testing so
um we know that our team is interpreting
a lot of somatic cancer variants but
also some potentially Drumline variants
in genes that are associated with the
hereditary cancer predisposing syndromes
now hsmd is not an exhaustive resource
for germline variants um associated with
cancer but definitely combining hsmd
with a well-established germline
all variant database like hgmd might be
um really useful for a genetic counselor
to
um figure out if a variant that they um
came across in a patient's report is
potentially germline or a somatic
variant that's that's been reported
before so um um I think that's that's
one way that hsmd could come in handy
yeah and I think a lot of genetic
counselors either watching or like
myself remember relying really heavily
on a GMD kind of been navigating the
transition to whole clinical home exome
sequencing and having access to the most
information as possible so I can see a
correlation with hsmd because another
challenge also relates to the
classification of variance in a German
in a somatic testing situation in that
not all Laboratories that are performing
testing
um are going to call a variant in the
same way
um and so the shift of how testing has
been completed for patients you know
driven by obviously some of the lower
cost of genetic testing capabilities
we're seeing the kind of versioning of
like larger semantic testing panels and
so you're testing people for a lot of
information potentially with a lot of
variants
and not always knowing what to do with
that information and so counseling I
think like you said before before after
and during the treatment testing process
I is is something that's being
recommended by a lot of the larger
institutions like ASCO and stuff and so
creating awareness around the
possibility of these incidental findings
and the resources that are available to
assist in these conversations I think is
really critical and so it seems like
hsmd can help in this way
yeah um as you said um with large NGS
panels whole like Zone whole genome
um you are hit with more information
then you know what to do with
um and you find yourself wondering how
to distill it down to its Essence to the
clinically actionable the clinically
significant information that can help
you find potential options for your
patient
um and that's what hsmd was built for it
was built to help and support labs and
clinical Professionals in their daily
work to your point about the difference
in classification systems for somatic
versus Drumline variants
um you know there have been articles
that also have reported that yes a lot
of the times presumed uh germline
pathogenic variants can get lost or
buried in a long list of variants of
Uncertain significance
um on a somatic report and so I think
definitely hsmd with its depth of
information on somatic cancer variants
and
um used along with a well-established
database like hdmd for Drumline variants
could really help a genetic counselor or
a variant analyst separate the true
somatic losses from germline variants
that may actually have significance
um in a germline context but not be
considered significant in a somatic
context so um I think we're you know
we're in this age where the complexity
and the abundance of um information that
we have to work with on an everyday
basis
um has necessitated this a better
um collaboration
um and the use of multiple resources
multiple tools to help um make your job
easier to help perform variant
interpretation with high accuracy and um
confidence so I think that is where I am
going to transition to showing you
um some more examples on hsmd let's dive
in yeah
hold on let me share my screen
um
all right so now let's look at a few
alterations this is the alteration
Explorer where you can search store and
filter to look for alterations of
interest and what shall we look at okay
Chelsea since you mentioned Lynch
syndrome since you were talking about
Lynch syndrome let's look at a variant
in a mismatch repair Gene mlh1
as you can see here we've it has pulled
up two different entries variants that
result in the same protein change but
have a different change of the coding
level so this one is clearly the one
that has been reported more frequently
in the literature so let's click on that
and it'll take us to the alteration page
and here you have this nice summary I'm
telling you about basically the
significance of this alteration so it
has been reported as a germline snip has
high allele frequency in the general
population
and in functional studies it was
reported to result in activities similar
to wildtap mlh1 and further our
scientists has also looked at clinvar to
verify that based on the most recent
submissions it had a likely benign
classification and so this was last the
date here should tell you when are
scientists last reviewed the
interpretation for this variant and
based on that it has a predicted no
effect or normal functional impact and
an actionability of tier four
and then oh yeah and I did want to talk
about how there are links to hgmd and
clinvar and dbsnip on here like we just
talked about
okay yeah if you click on that it will
take you to hgmd and as you can see hdmd
has assessed this one as a deceased
associated polymorphism
and
you can also you can also access
information from databases in a
different way because the kaijin KB
incorporates data from some databases as
well what you could do here is go to the
bibliography and filter by the category
database import and now you see that
there are multiple
findings extracted from clinvar cosmic
hgmd and so on
in addition to mlh1 and other mismatch
repair genes hsmd has extensive coverage
for the genes involved in homologous
recombination repair like braqqa 2 broca
one and others let's look at some
examples in ATM
okay
all right so
let's click on this um this particular
mutation from the alteration Explorer
you can see that it's a bus and it's
been classified as tier three
going to the alteration page you have a
nice summary similar to what I showed
you before for the mlh1 variant and the
conclusion is that the effect of this
mutation is unclear at this time so it's
it's a bus and you can be confident
knowing that it has been reviewed by
scientists as recently as April 2022.
that's a good example and
uh what else okay how about this one
yeah
so this one is the well-known mutation
ATM r3008c it has been reported to
result in a loss of ATM kinase activity
it is known in activating
it has been assessed as two or one and
it has been reported in age or online
context as well so this mutation can be
germline but from the bibliography
let's look at the database import
has also been reported in Cosmic so it
can be observed in both the somatic and
germline context
and you can use hsmd to not only get
a very useful summary of the clinical
significance of a particular variant in
cancer but it can also sometimes point
you to a potential germline origin and
you can use valuable resources like um
GMD to move to the next steps of your
process
so I can probably spend all day talking
about hsmd and showing you more examples
but I know that we are short on time so
I will now conclude and move on to the
trial details
so um you can sign up for a five-day
free trial of hsmd here's the link so
check it out and let us know what you
think
all right and it looks like we are ready
for the Q a segment of this session if
you haven't already please submit your
questions now again any questions that
we don't get to we will answer via email
um the one you provided at registration
all right Chelsea RT the first question
that we have today oh this one's an
interesting one Chelsea this one's for
you specifically
what do you like about the platform
oh that's a good question
um I like a lot of the things about the
platform and the fact that everything's
right there in one Fell Swoop I really
like the fact that it links out to
guideline and kind of have that other
information but one thing that my head
went to is because I did spend some time
in uh policy and and prioritization is
really where my head went is it would
potentially be helpful in writing
letters of medical necessity or making
an appeal information for a patient
related to medical management changes
for a patient I found those particularly
challenging in my previous courses of
work and so having that as a resource is
where my head went and something that I
think is really helpful
okay second question
how often is hsmd updated
I'll take that one uh currently hsmd's
updated
um every quarter so once in three months
um with each update we add
um
a whole lot of new variants and
um recently open clinical trials
recently approved drugs
um on average uh we add about 15 000 new
clinically absorbed variants with each
release
is this data available in gr38 is this
data set available as a download
great questions
currently the data in hsmd is in
grch37 hg19
um we are planning to enable
um grch38 as well
um
and so that's in the works currently the
data in hsmd is not available as a
download but we do have an API version
that you can use to integrate hsmd into
your analysis pipeline
okay next question does hsmd include
fusions or cnvs
yeah
um hsmd does include fusions and cnvs in
fact it was part of
um our most recent release
um and we're gonna keep building on our
fusion and CNB coverage in hsmd
all right and with that unfortunately
we've been having a lot of fun but it
looks like our time together is up again
if you'd like to learn more about hsmd
please visit our website at
digitalinsights.caijin.com explore hsmd
Ms Alexander Dr govarden thank you so
much for your time today I'd also like
to thank the audience for joining us
today and for their interesting
questions please note that the webcast
can be viewed on demand lab Roots will
alert you via email as soon as it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that with all of your colleagues
who may have missed today's event and
until next time take care everyone
goodbye thanks bye thank you bye